>>Julie Wiskirken: Greetings everybody I'm
Julia Wiskirken from the authors at Google
team in Los Angeles and today we're very excited
to welcome Seth Grahame-Smith.
Seth had visited us once before about three
years ago when things were just starting to
take off for him with the Pride and Prejudice
and Zombies and since then it's been a whirlwind
of activity and he was the co-creator, executive
producer of the MTV series the Hard Times
of RJ Berger.
He wrote the New York Times best seller Abraham
Lincoln Vampire Hunter and he adapted it for
the screen it's coming out this summer.
And he also wrote the screen play for Tim
Burton's Dark Shadows which is coming out
in a few weeks.
So and to end besides all that he has another
new book which is Unholy Night which just
came out yesterday and he is here to talk
to us about it today.
So let's welcome Seth.
[applause]
>>Seth Grahame-Smith: Thanks Julie.
Thanks everybody for taking time out of lunch
to come and hang out.
I'm excited to be here I had a great time
last time I was at Google.
Let me open with some pandering I guess.
What I do in books would be impossible without
you guys.
And we were just talking about this a minute
ago.
But the type of books that I write are research
intensive and I know that sounds crazy because
on the surface they're absurd and Abraham
Lincoln did not actually fight vampires as
far as I know and the three wise men were
not so far as I know swash buckling marauders.
But I like to weave in as much fact into my
fiction as I possibly can and in order to
do that I need to do quite a bit of research
and fifteen years ago I would've God forbid
actually had to go to a brick and mortar library
and not just any library but a research library
specific to the topic I was trying to research.
If I was doing Unholy Night who knows I might
have had to go to Jerusalem and combed through
some old New Testament Apocrypha and find
out what I was writing about or if I was writing
Lincoln I would have to go to Springfield
and comb through the archives at the Lincoln
Museum and Library.
Now I can do it all from home.
And there is a danger to that because you
have to not only go online and research things
but you have to be careful about which sites
you trust and which you don't you have to
get multiple sources you actually have to
do some legwork but thanks to you guys and
what goes on at Google and it's just I don't
know it's just completely changed my world
personally as an author.
So it's just, it's interesting to be here
and talk to you guys.
I typically like to do a Q and A more than
a lecture because I don't really like the
sound of myself lecturing at you and you guys
have better things to do than sit here and
listen.
But I will tell you a little bit about how
this particular book came to be.
Now last time I was here at Goggle I had just
written Pride and Prejudice and Zombies and
it was the sorta the beginning of the book
getting some notoriety.
As a result to that I came to see you guys,
I went on a book tour all over the country
and no matter where I went every book store,
this is back three years ago when there was
such a thing as book stores I don't know if
you guys remember-
[chuckles]
>>Seth Grahame-Smith: You use to actually
physically go and buy books at brick and mortar
stores.
No matter what store I would go into anywhere
in the country this is 2009 so it was the
bicentennial of Abraham Lincoln's birth and
it was also the absolute pinnacle the height
of the Twilight phenomena in literature.
This is like just as the movies were starting
to come out.
So no matter where I was I would see two tables
in the front of every book store.
There'd be the Twilight, True Blood table
right here and then there'd be the Abraham
Lincoln biography table.
And so I had made this cynical observation,
"boy if you could combine those two things
you know,
[laughter]
>>Seth Grahame-Smith: that would be a license
to print money right there
[laughter]
>>Seth Grahame-Smith: that's what that would
be.
And so this cynical observation led me as
it always does into a real research mode.
So I got on my browser--Chrome pandering.
[laughter]
>>Seth Grahame-Smith: And low and behold I
fell in love with the actual life story of
Abraham Lincoln which I didn't at that point
know that much about I knew, five dollar bill,
honest, axe, top hat okay just the things
we always that are in our DNA from the time
we're elementary school kids.
If you grow up in the United States that's
the four things you know about Lincoln.
What I didn't know is that his story was a
super hero origin story and I'm not talking
about the one that I wrote I'm talking about
the real one.
He is a guy with absolutely no education no
money no family connections he's awkward and
gangly he looks funny, he can't read and his
mom mysteriously dies when he's nine years
old and then that sets off a chain of events
where tragedy upon tragedy upon tragedy, there's
not a two year period in Lincoln's life after
he's nine years old that he doesn't, some
great tragedy befalls him and he has to pull
himself up by his boot straps get over his
suicidal tendencies, his melancholy, his famous
depression and just go on and so I became
fascinated with it and fascinated with how
that guy became arguably the greatest American
possibly and certainly if not the greatest
one of the greatest American presidents.
Where did he get that strength?
Where did he put the country on his shoulders
and pull back together etcetera.
So once I realized that this was a superhero
origin story it's like alright well now I
know a way to make it work with the vampires
where it's not just going to be, a weird sort
of conversion of all these facts and fictions
so Abraham Lincoln Vampire Hunter low and
behold, it was gonna be scrutinized because
it was the first thing I was doing after Pride
and Prejudice and low and behold it worked
and book came out did very well all of a sudden
I got a call from Tim Burton, "hey do you
wanna make a movie?" and I said, "great, I
think I can fit that into my schedule."
[chuckles]
>>Seth Grahame-Smith: So I wrote the screen
play for, and then, Tim was the producer on
that and then after I wrote the screen play
for Lincoln he said, "Hey I really like the
screen play do you wanna write Dark Shadows?"
I said, "I think I can fit that in."
[chuckles]
>>Seth Grahame-Smith: And in the meantime
so before, I knew, before my head had stopped
spinning literally like the last time I was
in the old Google building here in LA and
doing one of these my head had just started
to spin and before it stopped I found myself
in London at Pinewood Studios on the set of
Dark Shadows and here we were we were writing
and during that time I was also starting to
write Unholy Night and Unholy Night had a
very different sort of, for a lack of better
word genesis not pun intended but it wasn't
one of those things where it started as an
observation.
The idea for Unholy Night came to me out of
the blue.
Stephen King I don't know if anybody here
has ever read his book on writing.
But he talks about how there in his mind there
are these men in the basement that are sitting
around a table talking about ideas and coming
up with things, and then when that ideas ready
whether you're ready for it or not it goes
into the vacuum tube and goes upstairs to
your brain and it just hits you.
That never happens to me, my men in the basement
are probably all dead or lazy or something
but
[laughter]
>>Seth Grahame-Smith: I really have to whip
them into shape to like no let's work on this
idea let's develop this idea.
This was one of those things where I was here
in LA it was the middle of July or maybe June
it was summer it was hot and I was driving
up Robertson to what is now an empty store
but use to be a Blockbuster to return a digital
versatile disk you remember those DVD's right.
And you also remember Blockbuster before we,
you know.
So again back in the old days two years ago.
[chuckles]
>>Seth Grahame-Smith: And I was pulling into
the parking lot on this and just this question
just popped into my mind fully formed what
were the three wise men doing there really?
And that was is it that was the question and
it wasn't as if I was driving around New England
and looking at all the nativity scenes on
the front lawns and seeing the three wise
men lit up in plastic form and say, "Who the
hell are those guys really?"
This just came out of nowhere and it was an
intriguing question once again it led me into
my research mode which was, back on my then
updated latest beta of Chrome which was phenomenal
and not buggy at all and it was great.
[chuckles]
>>Seth Grahame-Smith: And reading essentially
passages from The New Testament.
Reading about how much do we know about the
three wise men from The New Testament turns
out virtually nothing and that really excited
me that intrigued me it's like the Gospel
of Luke and the Gospel of Matthew that's only
time you ever hear them mentioned.
All we know are basically the same four things
we know about Lincoln but in this case the
four things are come from the east, there's
three of them, they stop at Herod's they go
from Herod's to a manger in Bethlehem with
gold, frankincense, and myrrh pay their respects
on their way never to be heard from again.
Now that's, that to me is there's a lot of
room there to mess with that.
[chuckles]
>>Seth Grahame-Smith: And so I got really
excited by the where'd they get the gold,
frankincense, and myrrh?
Could they have say stolen it?
Why were they going to that manager that night?
Was it to pay their respects or was it perhaps
to find a place to hide because they had just
stolen gold and frankincense, so it starts
the ball rolling in your mind of like who
are these guys?
And it the process got rolling and I whipping
my men in the basement into shape and they
were getting on board with it and we were
all developing the idea and then I stopped
because I got really scared.
Because I had just been through the experience
of coming face to face with lifelong Jane
Austen fans who were like, "How dare you?"
[laughter]
>>Seth Grahame-Smith: And coming face to face
with some Lincoln scholars that were like,
"Yo, I don't even understand this, what are
you doing?"
[chuckles]
>>Seth Grahame-Smith: Now in all fairness
most of the people that are the biggest fans
of PPZ are Jane Austen's fans like life-long
fans.
And the vast majority of Jane Austen fans
are totally on board with my bastardization
of it.
Also to be fair the Lincoln community and
there is such a thing this community of historians
and scholars and lovers of Lincoln are almost
universally behind Abraham Lincoln Vampire
Hunter because they appreciate it for what
it is and it's not cheapening the legacy of
the real guy it's just brining new people
into the tent.
So I've been really lucky twice but I didn't
think that I would be so lucky the third time.
Because it's a little different when you're
dealing with the birth of Jesus-
[chuckles]
>>Seth Grahame-Smith: than dealing with a
Regency era romance novel.
As beloved as it is it's just a little different.
So I really had to sit and think about, "Okay
what am I trying to say here?"
And I made some very concrete decisions early
on before I wrote Unholy Night.
Number one Jesus was never gonna be more that
a two week old infant I was not gonna get
into the business of putting words into the
mouth of Jesus so that was number one.
And in fact Jesus the word never even appears
in the book it's always the infant or the
child even though it's all, everybody knows
who it is.
Number two Joseph and Mary always had to be
the paragons of virtue.
I wasn't about to have, I wasn't gonna do
to Mary the mother of Jesus what I did to
Lizzy in PPZ where she is a blood thirsty
sword woman and all that stuff, that was not
her turf.
They were just Joseph and Mary as you know
and loved them in the Bible.
Faithful devote committed believers.
And then number three I wanted the book to
say something about faith.
I didn't want it to just be like this romp
where I'm using Christianity as my canvas
I wanted to actually have a message.
Now my own personal religious history is a
little checkered I was born Seth Greenberg
not exactly a Christian name.
Then when I was three my parents split up
and my sort of wonderfully crazy mother who
was an English major loved the author the
English author Kenneth Grahame, Wind of the
Willows things like that and legally changed
my name when i was three to Grahame.
So stay with me.
[chuckles]
>>Seth Grahame-Smith: and then when I'm five
she marries an Episcopalian Smith and then
rather than saddling me with the unfortunately
alliterative Seth Smith she's like, "Maybe
we should hyphenate."
So that's how I became Seth Grahame-Smith
when I was five and it's also how I started
learning about Christianity because I was
this little five year old Jewish kid with
all these Jewish relatives and all this Jewish
lineage who all of a sudden was an Episcopal
altar boy, seriously, literally, altar boy.
[laughter]
>>Seth Grahame-Smith: And so I've always see
myself as kind of straddling these two worlds
and this was a very interesting exercise for
me because while it is about essentially the
birth of Christianity almost everyone in Unholy
Night is either an Arab or a Jew.
Cuz it turns out there weren't any Christians
back then.
So it was interesting from that point to sorta
delve back into really religious text reading
the New Testament going back and reading the
Old Testament for background and for mythology
and then reading the Apocrypha that's written
centuries after The New Testament there's
actually a great tradition that sprung up
in Europe especially about the three wise
men and in Asia everyone wants to claim them
as their own even though they don't really
appear in the Bible that much after, at all
after they leave.
There's great traditions and festivals dedicated
to them in Europe in the book that's where
the names of the three wise men come for Gaspar,
Melchior, and Balthazar are the traditional
three names of the wise men and I don't know
where they came from but somebody decided
that was the case so that's what I stuck to.
So anyways the point being I really wanted
to say something about faith I didn't want
to pander and be, I'm afraid of Christian
backlash so therefore I'm gonna overdo it.
But I also didn't want to offend anyone's
sensibility so that's a real tight rope.
I wanted devout Christians to be able to read
this and go, "Wow what a great fun ride and
it made me think weirdly differently about
my faith."
And I wanted staunch agnostic or atheistic
to be able to read this and go, "Wow what
a fun ride."
So that's a tough one and we'll see if it
happens that way or not but it was a fun one
to write and it was a real challenging one
to write because unlike Lincoln I didn't have
the crutch of everyday of Lincoln's life at
this point has been chronicled.
I can go on there's a site called the Lincoln
Log where you can literally enter a date at
any point of Lincoln's existence and there
is a check that he signed from that day for
groceries or there's Lincoln wrote a letter
to Mary about this on this day you know everything
and so if I get lost in the narrative I'm
like well what was Lincoln really doing okay
I'll write about that.
Now you have Scripture and a tradition of
the Nativity and you know that baby Jesus
had to get out of Judea and into Egypt before
Herod got his hands on him but you don't know
how he got there you don't know what happened
after he got there so that was where I had
to invent within the lines of various pieces
of Scripture.
So that's how the book came to be.
It came out yesterday and I just don't know.
I'm in that zone right now where I got a an
email from my publisher this morning and she
said, "Unlike a movie or anything like that
the release date of a book is the day where
the author gets all dressed up in the tuxedo
and gets ready and does his hair all perfect
and then nothing happens."
[laughter]
>>Seth Grahame-Smith: Because books are different
it's not a movie where I'm not checking my
watch to see where the grosses come in tonight
and we'll know how we're doing.
It takes time you don't know and reviews make
the difference and books are much more of
a slowly chumming word of mouth thing so that's
why I'm here hocking my goods to you fine
people, but with that I was hoping to kinda
turn it over to some questions and to see
what sorts of things interest you guys.
I'm certainly interested in what you guys
do we were just talking before about, I was
asking so what specifically happens in this
office versus other Google offices well it
sounds like everything happens here it sounds
like Chrome happens here and YouTube happens
here and it sounds those awesome new Google
glasses that I'm sure you guys are gonna let
me try out before I leave
[laughter]
>>Seth Grahame-Smith: happen here.
And otherwise I'm gonna make one of those
parodies you guys watch out, that are
[laughter]
>>Seth: But no it's really exciting but what's
exciting to me is again I'm going back again
into pandering mode but it's pandering with
truth it, what's exciting to me is that everything
you guys do in this building I use as a tool
for what I do.
The book trailers for my books launch on YouTube,
the one for Lincoln about a million and a
half hits now it's crazy and that book trailer
that we just uploaded to YouTube completely
set the tone for the whole campaign for the
book.
I have to do a Hangout I have to I have my
Google plus all set up but I have to do Hangout
so I apologize for not having done one yet.
But I use your browser, I use your video,
I use in the future I'm sure I'll use your
glasses too.
But so it's really cool.
So if you guys have questions for me that
would be exciting because I do better in a
conversation format than I do in a lecture
format.
Yes.
>> man 1: The obvious question when are you
gonna start work on Sergey Brin the Batman?
[laughter]
>>Seth: Oh man, listen
>>Seth Grahame-Smith: Sergey Brin the Batman
I mean you think about it he's first of all
he's one of the few guys in the world that
could actually afford to do that.
[laughter]
>>Seth Grahame-Smith: Already has his own
awesome plane from what I hear.
Has bat glasses with facial recognition and
man that's a great idea.
Listen I will do it, I'll start tomorrow if
I can get paid in stock.
[laughter]
>>Seth Grahame-Smith: So hopefully Sergey's
watching, yeah available anytime you know
how to reach me.
[laughter]
>>Seth Grahame-Smith: Yes
>>woman 1: Hi Big fan of PPZ and looking forward
to reading this book.
I was just concerned when you were talking
about it the reaction that you might get from
some Christian fundamentalists.
They can get pretty scary
>>Seth Grahame-Smith: sure
>>woman 1: And I just kinda wanted to make
sure that you're fully aware of what you've
done
[laughter]
>>woman 1: Cuz
>>Seth Grahame-Smith: Do you know what you've
done?
>>woman 1: There's some crazy people out there
>>Seth Grahame-Smith: Yeah
>>woman 1: and they can be violent.
>>Seth Grahame-Smith: And my picture is in
the book.
>>woman 1: Yeah
[laughter]
>>Seth Grahame-Smith: Yes, and I'm doing this
I'm being recorded right now.
[laughter]
>>Seth Grahame-Smith: I'm not and I'll tell
you why.
Is because I think that for two reasons.
Number one there is always gonna be a group
of people you're never going to affect your
just never gonna change an opinion.
The fact that the wise men were even characters
in my book that Mary and Joseph were even
characters in my book is gonna be offensive
to some people.
I respect that.
I think however, when people read the book
and they understand that the journey that
Balthazar goes through in the book especially
because he's our way in he's the wise man
who we care about the most in the book.
He goes on a very positive pro-faith journey.
And that was a choice and again I made a conscious
choice that I wanted to be exciting and entertaining
and I wanted to be dark and bloody and cool
but not offensive.
And what I did was I wanted the book again
to have a very pro-faith message.
Balthazar when he begins is a staunch an atheist
as your even gonna find.
He doesn't have any time for the old stories
he doesn't have any time for all that superstition
and whatever.
And he's got a very painful past that we sort
of come to know throughout the course of the
book.
By the end of the book he is not only saved
the baby Jesus but he's saved himself in order
through his understanding of his openness
to belief, his openness to faith, and his
openness to acceptance and so I think that
when people read the book and they understand
that.
I think that they'll realize that it is not
at any in any way a critique or criticism
of faith it's actually a positive message
about faith.
Just done in a very genre kinda crazy way
so believe me I thought about that a lot during
the process and the last thing I wanted to
do was pit myself against any religious group
or anything so.
>>woman 1: The only other point that I would
make about that is that I'm not worried about
the people who actually read the book.
>>Seth Grahame-Smith: Sure
>>woman 1: I worry about the people who don't
read the book who know basically that the
cliff notes the summary of what it's about
or just the fact that he even goes in that
area in any kind of comedic manner.
Those are the people to worry about cuz they're
the ignorant ones.
They're the ones who are not gonna read it
and say.
"Oh well this is actually pro-faith and it's
not that bad."
>>Seth Grahame-Smith: Yeah, I think that there's
very really little I can do about that to
be honest-
>>woman 1: Absolutely
>>Seth Grahame-Smith: with you.
There's really little I can do.
I mean
>>woman 1: Except for get a body guard.
>>Seth Grahame-Smith: No, No look I think
that first of all it would be flattering if
people cared enough about the book to get
that worked up about it in a way because it's
hard for books to get noticed these days.
And I'm sure there are people that are in
my life that would be like, "I would welcome
some controversy we would sell more books."
Of course I have to deal with the fallout
personally but when Harry Potter came out
there were probably 5% of people out there
that said it's about witchcraft we gotta ban
it we gotta burn it we gotta keep our kids
away from it.
I'm guessing that's the same 5% of people
that are just gonna be like, we gotta ban
this book we gotta burn this book cuz it deals
with scared text and there's nothing I can
do except repeatedly say the truth of, "This
is pro-faith and read the book, please read
the book."
But again I've been pleasantly surprised twice
now by the reaction of people who I was afraid
of being really critiqued by and attacked
by.
They either haven't critiqued and attacked
or they've read the book and have actually
come around to enjoying it so, yeah.
>>man 2: Coming off of adapting a book to
a movie was it hard to, were you tempted at
all to write this keeping the future movie
in mind and setting things up to be stageable
or did you really want it to be a book first
and who knows what will happen.
>>Seth Grahame-Smith: That's a great question.
I mean it was a challenge to be honest with
you not to write the movie of the book or
the book of the movie or whatever.
Coming off of adapting Lincoln I realized
that there were a lot of things I could've
made my life easier that could've made my
life easier having written Lincoln the book
like, having a central villain for one.
My book doesn't have a central villain.
Lincoln doesn't have a central villain.
It doesn't have a thrilling climax it doesn't
have any of the real things that make a movie
work and so the process for adapting Lincoln
was really laborious because a lot of that
stuff had to be invented from scratch for
the movie.
So I'm sure that subconsciously that effected,
for instance, Unholy Night has a very clear
central villain, it has a thrilling climax,
it has all the things that were one to adapt
it into a movie would make one's life easier.
[chuckles]
>>Seth Grahame-Smith: But other than that
I was coconscious also of not writing the
book of the movie.
I didn't wanna I didn't want this book to
be the novelization of some future movie I
wanted it to be a book and so I actually in
some cases went out of my way to write things
that I knew were never going to be in the
movie they were just tangential or internal
or but I'm sure that subconsciously I was
influenced.
It's impossible to say that I wasn't.
So how 'bout two more then I'll, you guys
can go back to work.
>>woman 2: I've got one actually.
>>Seth Grahame-Smith: Yes
>>woman 2: About your research on the Unholy
Night.
I don't remember their being a whole lot about
the wise men in the four gospels in the Bible
and I'm just curious did you look at all of
those other gospels.
>>Seth Grahame-Smith: Oh yeah
>>woman 2: And was there more in there or
did you just kind of invent most of it?
>>Seth Grahame-Smith: No, Matthew and Luke
is really were it all comes from and then
there's also a lot of later text that the
Apocrypha they're called that are just sort
of, whether they be like the Gnostic gospels
or things like that or even like the Koran
has, there are parts of the Koran that deal
with Christ's journey as an infant so it's
interesting.
You take all these different sources and you
sort of put together a patch work of a truth
of a story.
We know their names are Balthazar, Melchior,
and Gaspar and you know that while Joseph
and Mary were traveling with the baby Jesus
that certain miracles occur that we don't
necessarily hear about in The New Testament
at least not The King James or The New International
editions.
So there are a lot of things in there that
are interesting but most of what we know about
the wise men comes from oral tradition comes
from just stories that are handed down through
the ages and legends that have sprung up around
them and not very much in the Bible itself
which in a way was freeing but also in a way
made the job harder because so much has to
be invented and yet be respectful and work
within the framework of what's there so how
about one last question then we can, Yes okay.
>>man 2: So for me as I was growing up there
was there are books that I distinctly remember
and I think that it was just as I was reading
books and maturing that really stick in my
head over time and I kind of always think
back to fondly upon those books and judge
other books by those what kind of
>>Seth Grahame-Smith: Sure
>> man 2: you know
>>Seth Grahame-Smith: Sure what are my sign
post books the books that I hold up and.
Well as a kid you know my dad, my step-father
was a used a rare book dealer and we had five
thousand books in our basement that we converted
into a library and most of what he was interested
in was genre was horror, science fiction,
fantasy and so I grew up being inundated with
Heinlein, Asimov, with Bradbury and when I
was twelve it was King and King was king and
King is still king in my I'm an unabashed,
not disciple that's wrong word especially
in this context but
[laughter]
>>Seth Grahame-Smith: but King lover.
Unapologetically to this day and I just read
everything that I get my hands on of King.
One of the ones that really stuck with me
early on was Skeleton Crew and It those were
big in the eighties for me another one though
real one that got under my skin in a big way
that I think about all the time was Something
Wicked this Way Comes.
Which was Ray Bradbury's the story of the
traveling carnival.
Mr. Dark coming to town and it was really
a great it's a book about boys aspiring to
be men and men aspiring to be boys and a story
about regret and small towns it's just a beautifully
written story so I tend to judge myself and
everything against King and those guys that
sort of cannon of genre authors.
Okay one last in the back.
Yes?
>>man 3: When you did your research did you
need to consult to any religious scholars,
theologians or anyone like that?
>>Seth Grahame-Smith: Yeah it's interesting
I didn't consult with I would say people of
deep faith let's say during the writing of
the book but after I had written the manuscript
I had several people of different faiths and
of devout faith that had no connection to
me directly read the book and sort of give
feedback about it.
And honestly the person this was another encouraging
thing about my impending assassination but
[laughter]
>>Seth Grahame-Smith: Was that one of the
more self-proclaimed evangelistic deeply devout
Christians really loved the book and I got
a long letter back from her about, how it
had been handled delicately and about how
so that was really encouraging to know.
So, well thank you guys for taking time and
it's great it's honestly it's really cool
to be here and I'm huge fan of what you guys
are doing so thank you and thanks for coming
to hear me yap thanks.
[applause]